[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview
a first look at what's on the front
pages as they arrive
coming up we'll see what's making the
headlines with the political editor of
the new statesman
stephen bush and the parliamentary
sketch writer
madeline grant they'll be with us right
through
until midnight so let's see what's on
some of those front
pages and the metro leads with nhs
bosses
begging people not to delete the covert
app after half a million people were
pinged
and forced to self-isolate last week
amid fears the app could be too
sensitive indeed the telegraph reports
that some people have been pinged
through the walls
of their neighbors when their
neighbours tested positive and amid
worries the nation could grind to a halt
the mail asks what kind of state
are we in the guardian leads with the
floods in germany that have killed
dozens of people
a sun is angry that computers have been
seized in a raid investigating how
cctv of former health secretary matt
hancock kissing an aide
came to be leaked the paper says it was
the public's
right to know about it the yorkshire
post has word of boris johnson's plans
to offer more devolved
powers to counties and towns
the financial times leads with news that
london-based digital bank revolut has
raised new finance to make it
the biggest private tech company
in the uk and as i said we're joined
by stephen bush and by madeleine grant
welcome to you both and you have to
guide me through this i haven't done it
for a while
so um madeline we're going to start with
you and
all this pinging going on um
500 000 a week
being pinged it says uh that's
unsustainable isn't it
absolutely we're in there you know many
people are referring to this as the
pandemic where people are are being are
being pinged on mass and then having to
retreat
in isolation for ten days and it's
creating all sorts of effort
up and down the country uh particularly
in schools but also
um as we reported we've led on reports
that
neighbours are being told to
self-isolate because the test and trace
app is pinging them through the
neighbor's wall um and our reporters
discovered hundreds of people
complaining on social media about being
pinned by the app despite them not
having even left their homes
um what we think has happened is the app
uses
bluetooth technology which is supposed
to alert people to their proximity to
someone who later tested positive
but it looks as if the bluetooth signals
may be far too strong
and therefore strong enough to go
through walls and therefore far too
sensitive to distinguish between whether
there's a wall or wind window uh
separating you from the infected contact
um or nothing um and elsewhere the metro
reports that thousands are ditching the
app
after just because of the sheer volume
of pinging and um
given the havoc who can really blame
them well that it stephen i mean that's
going to be the
problem isn't it i see the telegraph
saying that um
that some people are being forced to
self-isolate despite never having come
into face-to-face contact so this uh
through-the-wall thing
um with a positive case i mean people
will
be tempted to just turn it off won't
they
well yeah i mean of course i think this
is a you know really
good i think it's good journalism it's
really terrible story on the front page
of the telegraph but it's a really
important story because you know
if you live in a flat or a terrorist
house
um you will occasionally just see on
your bluetooth right
neighbors speakers neighbors phones
neighbors wi-fi i mean
yeah if i wanted to inflict my bad music
on the people through that wall over
there
you can see i i could do so because i
can pair with
with their speakers anytime that i like
but that actually creates a real problem
uh if people are worried they are going
to get pinged when they don't need to be
because can you imagine what would
happen if people's fire alarms started
going off
when there was a fire next door they'd
take the batteries out and then they
would eventually get caught in a fire
because ultimately the the pings aren't
just there to annoy us right
they are an important biosecurity tool
to
as we as we move to normality but if we
have a situation where people don't
trust and they're not going to have
their days and also crucially
if we have a sort of stop go lockdowns
in which you know a business has to
close because all this waiting staff get
pinged
yeah hotel might get it it's money back
but the local restaurants aren't going
to serve any of those customers if the
guests get pinged
then you can't have the economic
unlocking uh
that that you know we all but the
government in particular of course are
hoping for
uh so it's a big and really important
story this yeah and
madeline you mentioned i think it was
you mentioned the metro
and already saying that thousands are
ditching the
nhs app i mean the government was
talking about making it less
sensitive but with cases going up that's
going to be
well it's not straightforward is it no
it's not politically straightforward
they'll be worried about tweaking the
system in any way given the
the rising case numbers but i really do
think that given the level of chaos it's
causing you know in schools i wrote
kids you've got entire classrooms in
some cases having to isolate for
10 days at home because one of their
schoolmates has tested positive
you know as if they hadn't lost enough
contact time you have a real problem as
steven said
that what a device that was supposed to
kind of open up the country in some way
instead
seems to be acting like something of a
straight jacket
um and you know there must be a better
way of doing this
you would think that perhaps a system
where uh you know with testing
rather than isolation uh makes sense
given that the scale of the crisis
but of course you know i i feel for the
ministers right now because they have a
quite a difficult situation on their
hand whether hands where there is a
great deal that is
still unknown and they're having to make
these decisions with
perhaps imperfect knowledge of the kind
of trade-offs that are on the on the
table
yeah i mean on the broader issue stephen
i mean there is
i suppose this question of the the
freedom day itself i was talking to
david nabarro the world health
organization today and he said that he's
surprised that they're
lifting the sort of legal restrictions
and he said they must know
something that i don't i mean um with
the cases going up
will more questions be asked about the
whole lifting of these restrictions
yes but not i think that in a way that
will lead to sort of any tangible change
look
the political problem here if you're
boris johnson someone who has a
transactional relationship with his mps
they like him because he's a winner but
there is not a kind of
hardcore of johnsonites in the
parliamentary party you're going to go
you know
we've got to stick with this guy no
matter what is that the parliamentary
party is
sick and tired of lockdowns they want an
end to this
they want businesses to be able to go
back to trading they want to be able to
return to the world as it was in january
2020.
and the only way that we are going to
get a lockdown extension would be
a hefty tory rebellion and those
measures passing with opposition party
votes
boris johnson is yeah i mean you can
make a good argument he ought to want to
do this anyway
but um he is rightly going to be very
nervous about the political consequences
of um passing lockdown in that manner
and you know i think it's very hard to
see seeing as we know the public is
already not that into this unlocking
we can see when the data is where it is
there will ever be a situation where
where the prime minister goes do you
know what i do fancy creating this big
problem for myself and my own back
benches
yeah madeline we've got uh the mail and
they're
talking about pandemic paralysis
and uh they're talking about what kind
of state are we in and uh
a police arrive in a riot van they say
at the home of a petrified school girl
to interrogate her over the quarantine i
mean
so they're talking about that the mirror
they seem to agree
they're saying that uh britain is
grinding to a halt
but the mail are really outlining
what they think is uh going wrong with
this
yeah exactly they create a real sense of
um
chaos written um in which we have
factories on the verge of
shutting um hospitals having to scrap
operations because
so many workers are having to
self-isolate there are also reports
elsewhere i've seen that um very large
proportion of border officials are
having to
um to isolate as well because they're
coming into contact with people who've
a great deal of people during the day
and some of whom may have tested
positive
after the event um so i think all told
you do have a system that seems to be
um unsustainable and um also a kind of a
growing backlash
i don't think it's just from the media
either i'm seeing
even more more friends and family who
particularly people with children who
are seeing the kind of the
the the impact that these continued
isolation periods are having
having on them um often when they don't
appear to be displaying any sort of
symptoms and
may even have tested negative but
nevertheless the rules remain in place
so steve i mean what's the answer do you
think it's a very it is a very difficult
one for the government isn't it
it's very difficult i think given that
the businesses can
we can all adapt to anything other than
uncertainty
uh i think given that um
while um the global vaccine or aids
varies but crucially
while the vaccine program here here in
the uk is at the speed it is
um you do still have to have a measure
of peeing if you want to unlock
um i think we are better off just in
terms of the economic and social damage
extending the point where we unlock in
that final sort of wave
a little bit further into the um into
the summer
so that we can uh when the autumn term
starts
uh you don't have schools having to
isolate businesses having these stop go
unlockings because
that ultimately is the thing which is
destructive to children's learning and
destructive to the economy is
these continual unplanned sort of
cessations in the ability to trade
yeah do you i saw you nodding there
madeline you agree
i agree that it's very difficult i don't
i wouldn't it's a
it's a very difficult calculation to
make i'm just that i don't have to be
the one doing it i personally would
favor a situation where instead of
making
people isolate there needs to be a root
out of that if they've tested
negative um perhaps it could work a bit
like it does with
holidays if you've been to an annualist
country you can have a
test to release on day five and that can
get you out that bit sooner
i think anything like this particularly
when you're dealing with school children
who
themselves are at very low risk of
complications from the virus but the
prospect of further disruption i think
poses a very grave risk to them
okay thanks very much uh for the moment
uh stay with us
coming up does the leaking of cctv
of the former health secretary kissing
an aide warrant a
criminal inquiry the son thinks not
we'll discuss that next welcome back
you're watching the
press preview on sky news with me now
stephen bush and
uh madeline grant and we're going to
talk about
the sun newspaper and which of course
carried those uh
photographs of matt hancock and now
they're talking about computers and
phone sees in this
uh investigation over the cctv
uh pictures and uh so well uh madeline i
mean
is it okay or is it an attack on
whistleblowing
well the sun seems pretty outraged that
this is happening at all
um and i do sympathize because of course
without
without these leaks we wouldn't have
known about you know the hypocrisy of
the rank hypocrisy of one of the chief
architects and implementers of lockdown
rules
um but on the other hand i could sort of
see the other side because you know this
was a huge security breach from within
government which raises
all kinds of questions about you know
securing the parliamentary estate
and securing all the highly sensitive
data that resides there so
in a way it would be extraordinary if
they weren't trying to get to the bottom
of it
uh stephen i mean they clearly think you
know criminal offence has taken place
um is it and what does the sun say
overkill
probe well
look the the difficulty is exactly as
madeline says and it speaks to the wider
issue of how we treat whistleblowers
full stop
right which is um yes there may be
serious issues about the security of
whitehall which do need to be
investigated fully
um however we know that in not just in
this country in pretty much every
country right
if you make a protected disclosure if
you're a whistleblower you are often
ending up unemployed for life uh your
life is often ruined
even if people then go well thank
goodness we knew about this that was
quite an important disclosure as i think
most people do think this was quite an
important disclosure
so i think it does really speak to the
difficult question of how you get that
balance right between
um making sure that you don't have
security breaches but also
you do protect the important right of
whistleblowers
and uh i think we are getting the
balance wrong in general and quite
probably getting the balance wrong in
this specific case as well
yeah i mean there will be course people
all over whitehall who want to know
you know interestingly how it was filmed
i mean sadly javid came in and got rid
of the thing
didn't he the camera i mean i don't even
know
i can't remember did matt hancock know
it was i can't did he know the camera
was there
i think they thought it was a smoke
detector or something like that
it was like a kind of innocuous thing
that you might have in the office at all
times
which is why it passed unnoticed for
such a long time
um but i guess that does also beg the
question of you know if a member of
staff who know who knows it well
can couldn't put a device like that in
there it sort of it makes you think that
perhaps a hostile actor could also
do the same um and you know
especially hiding in plain sight in the
way that it seems to have been
yeah i mean stephen i mean the sun would
say this wouldn't they but they do say
it's a menace to the free press
yeah i mean look i think they do have a
point right and then someone comes
through and makes disclosure to a
journalist uh
of something which is clearly of
significant significant significance by
the
former secretary of state the the center
he had to resign
i do think there is a problem then if
you have a situation where the full
might of the state then
then comes after these people as they do
always do with whistleblowers not just
here but you know in general
so yeah i i find myself for once in full
agreement with the sun's front page
yeah and let's just have a quick look at
the metro before we uh
go to the break and uh there it is uh
this is bakayo saka um i knew
racists hate uh is that apostrophe right
there
uh racist hate was coming and
it's interesting isn't it because this
is the third player
after marcus rashford and jaden sancho
they've all
um issued statements and
you know what's interesting and we'll
talk about this because we've got to go
to the break
we'll talk about this more afterwards
but it's interesting
these footballers now feel
that they can speak out like this and
and can answer um
these uh these racists like this have we
got another minute we have got another
minute so i just well
madeline what did you think of these
statements all pretty similar
yeah pretty similar and very moving
um for various reasons i mean they all
seem to follow
i couldn't get over the fact that so
many of these these posts aside from
very movingly highlighting the volume of
appalling racism that's been directed at
them
there's also a kind of element of we let
you down
you know they keep apologizing for not
having won the euros which is i'm not
sure i can deal with any of these posts
i'm just you know i feel so proud of
them
but um they've all of them have also
been calling for
further action from social media
companies to do
to clamp down on it and we've already
seen how
the footballers are so so beloved in
this country and have already made uh
you know some effective political
campaigning that this is the kind of
thing that will really
um spur action and action has already
taken place within government